um you you mentioned TI you guys uh this
the guy who does these pranks where he
says shout out shout out white do M man
I've been following we we bu me and him
building we we built the relationship
off this so we I've been following this
guy for a long time and and I think he's
funny and cuz he does other stuff
besides just you know that and by the
way he does look really white yeah but
people don't know he's not he's not
that's what I'm saying I know he's not
but he looks really like even if
somebody took it the wrong way and he
tried to explain like no no no no this
is what my parents look like I don't
know if you can get that
far so that prank was real like your
guys' reaction was like real it wasn't
it looked a little set up if I'm being
honest what I will be honest with you
is it's way more that happened that day
before y'all got to see what y'all see
so we'll leave at that okay but you
would be I I would just say that you
would be like top five guy wouldn't
prank I put it like this it was a it was
a lot interesting that day and that was
realized that day yeah so we just leave
it at that man you know yeah okay that's
fair do Mike he he good people though
man and I you know just I'm just see see
cuz we've been seeing some some of these
pranksters like I don't know if you saw
couple week ago some dude got shot at
the mall it's all on yeah like yo you
got to be careful man people ain't
playing around these days because you
know like the worst thing I can tell you
now the worst
thing with me would be if I'm with my
kids it ain't nothing nobody going to be
able to tell me nothing you know what
I'm saying it's like
so but I also gave him game too you know
like I told him hey man like this ain't
the always ways of going viral ain't
good and this isn't like a a sustainable
scalable way to do do it like do it and
have a an audience and then then start
doing skits or then make a tub movie or
just start acting do you know I think
dreki has done like such an incredible
job of like and his ass is funny with
the [__] that he I don't I don't know
how he wakes up with the thought process
he he has the most specific like
scenario videos that you just relate to
and you never yeah I'm saying like and
you're just like bro like the one with
the where he was playing the girls like
who are security guards at the front
desk and he's like chewing gum and like
on the
phone my homie too man he's great but
he's done he's like built an in he's got
a sports agency like it's really crazy
it is you see um I just did it was I did
a skit that just came out with me and
Jack funny definitely should check Jack
funny out man on 313 he's super dope but
you know if you really pay attention
I've been in that world with a lot of
comedians already so I been doing I've
been doing skits since Vine days Vine
was
lit before it was Tik Tock yeah did you
go to um The Comedy Mothership in
Austin that's Joe Rogan's Club his ComEd
no no no no there's some dope comedians
out of Texas right now Ralph Barbosa
have you heard of him yeah I just met
him he's [__] hilarious um uh another
one live in Texas is it Matt R yeah yeah
heo he's lit yeah um I think the last
last time I was in Austin for comedy was
with Dave Chappelle oh that's so yeah so
I went to Comedy Store once in uh
Hollywood I go to Comedy Store a lot but
I went one time and it was one of the
times where they were like hey everyone
needs to check their phone cuz
Chappelle's about to practice all his
[__] tonight with no like you had no
idea so you like pay for like a you know
$25 ticket to just see you know whoever
they put on stage and Dave Chappelle
comes out lights up a cigarette he did
like 2 hours yeah he always you know he
he usually ends trade day for me with
the comedy show it's amazing so yeah yes
now that's my brother for real for real
man and
um also it's big for him to like like he
uplift me like no other like he he be
proud like a big brother for just the
stuff that I I do too you know what I'm
saying and stuff like that give you
energy to keep going I think like what
he does is so inspiring because he's
like the person who walked away
from the biggest show like the biggest
sketch comedy television show ever I
think he had 30 million dollars on the
table and he's like nah this don't feel
right yeah one thing and he got it right
back he stands for what he stands for
and he's just does what he wants like if
he don't feel like if it don't feel good
he ain't going to [__] with it you know
what I mean he definitely more people
should move that way yeah yeah he's he's
authentic like money like money ain't
everything you know what I'm saying you
know in this day and age for some people
it is for people like us is it's not
worth jeopardizing your principles your
morals and your legacy you know mhm cuz
right now for for people like myself
Legacy is important the stuff that I do
in a community fighting that's all part
of my legacy my story my kids will be
able to to be proud of who they pops was
you know right right no for sure it's
crazy too because your legacy is like
cemented at this point and you've kind
of gone from like being like a guy if
you really weren't a like a Houston or
Texas hip-hop fan you just knew about
Trey CU it was like the guy in Te who
runs Houston it's like the guy you don't
want to [__] with in Texas you know what
I'm saying um and like you know fast
forward 15 years you're like very much a
community leader you're very much like
when you think of like you know when
when I think of what you and Mr Rogers
were doing out there Shout Out Mr Rogers
um just crazy just like not a lot of
people would roll their sleeves up and
like actually do the work to like help
their neighbors I I tell people or or
also not just that by the way like I've
seen you post if some sort of situation
happens so we do a lot um to touch on
the stuff with Rogers like people don't
really realize the
time relief gang right yeah they don't
realize the time and everything that we
went through and dealt with you know
from Health to family to just
we dealt with a lot trying to do what we
could do for everybody you know
and that that's the part that that's
always going to be implanted in both me
and him but you know to the rest of way
they don't really they only see what we
showing that that was only 20% of what
we do you see what I'm saying like you
got to think you're not doing it for the
wrong Reon we only doing it when we show
it we show for awareness because it
gives people more help and it also
plants seed to show people that they can
do things to help people you know like
everybody think you got to be
millionaires to help people and that
ain't the case sometimes don't even take
money it may take the time or just the
ear you know and like nobody seeing us
sleeping in cars not being able to to
eat for days or or you know just
different stuff like it's a lot that
came with that man but we dedicated to
and I even to this day I'm something
happen I'm one of the ones that's going
front I was going to say can you give us
like a a random example cuz like I've
seen it a bunch like if there's a
situation where something bad happens to
somebody or you know there's an
unfortunate thing like you'll pull
together your resources you'll post
about it you know can you give me a
situation in which you just helped
somebody that cuz I I think some people
who don't really necessarily follow you
they know about what you guys did in the
hurricane but you guys do stuff all the
time for people oh man it's it's too
much to name um they talked to me
earlier about Miss Martha which was
the 77 year old lady they took to jail I
mean the lady they took to jail for $77
she was like 80 something years old y
you know I we I got there for her um
start working to rebuild the house
raised her like 40 50,000 and um done a
lot of different stuff for her um you
got that
um the man that they they showed me they
was trying to take his land in Texas
elder man went out there spoke for him
um RP to the homie Canal I don't know if
you see the dude who he had less than a
few days to live he was on hospice and I
was saw him recently he passed away
right I was the Mexican dude right yeah
well no he's Indian oh okay okay yeah
yeah but I saw the food Community Pages
posted him and he just passed away maybe
two days ago right so when they reached
out I was one of his um one of his
favorite rappers I believe it's
paage that we just give it 8 to 10,000
followers and um but then them his
biggest thing that he wanted was to be
able to get to the people and motivate
them you know the show people even with
him knowing his time was coming still be
grateful I just the the video that
really like was crazy to see was I I
think it was a video he posted the day
before he passed or two days before he
passed and he was barely hanging on but
he was still very like yeah and I you
for me for me to take him from to eight
or 10,000 people being able to see who
he is to almost 200,000 in a matter of a
couple days help spread his message Man
spread his message like no other you had
people shout out to the rock you had
people everybody from all across the
world reaching out you know what I'm
saying
so it it's just so many different things
that I do you know you had the you had
the recent hurricanes and uh in the
Mississippi you know I'm I'm out the
front line with that it's just it's so
much different stuff that we do yeah for
sure yeah yeah then you know we still
fighting for Banna Taylor we still want
Justice for that um special [__] you to
Daniel Cameron and you know we still
keep it going yeah it's crazy too
because if you think about like you know
some of the activism that came out of
the
pandemic you know it felt at a at a
certain point in time like it was just
trendy for some people but you got to
but I'm but I let me finish my what I
was going to say was and then and then
you'll see people like cord day you'll
see people like my son people like you
like it's like yo this is not just
because it's popular to post a black
Square on Instagram or it's popular to
spread awareness cuz because we're stuck
in the house so so the thing with that
is people don't really understand again
they only know what they see they don't
know our lives are at risk every day I
don't know if you know you know me my
son we moved yeah I'm going to get to
that too we we moved to Kentucky we were
living there wow so imagine being follow
Follow by helicopters you you getting
random unmarked cars Following being
shot at whether it may be tear gas
different stuff um you know we've been
we've been through a lot man I'm talking
about any anything when anything can go
the same man Daniel Cameron just for us
showing up to his house had us arrested
tried to give us felonies but you can't
do nothing to the the officers that cold
blooded kill Banna Taylor crazy you see
saying like but I I I tell people when
it come to stuff like that anytime we
leave out the house [__] it's not
guaranteed we coming back that [__] just
as serious as the street life when you
dealing with going against crooked
officers the cops are biggest gang in
the and they crazy police literally move
like a
gang say I'm not going I'm not going I'm
I'm a realistic person I'm not going to
pin it on all of them because even times
when we were arrested and stuff like
that you have officer Poli us aside like
man I respect what y'all doing I ha it
got to be this way yeah I would say this
like obviously most cops are good but I
just mean in terms of like the culture
of police there's Unwritten laws that
they had they follow it is very much you
know's so crazy it be funny right like
when people talk about the streets and
the industry snitching right
mhm officers feel the same way if you go
tell on them that's what I was going to
say the same way like if a cop snitches
on another cop that cop life yeah you
outcast
so it's definitely the same [__] it is
definitely the same [__] it is